Hello my name is Catherine Parker, and I'm going to have an interview
conversation, I should say, more like a conversation with
Adrian Watson, for Visible Lives: An Oral History Project at the New York Public
Library.
It is January 21st, 2015, and this is being
recorded at City College, in Manhattan.
So Adrian, can you tell me
about where you come from.
Well. I was born in New York City uh
actually I was born at home, um
So you know ... that's basically, you know ... pretty much I was
raised here, um,
You know, I grew up in up in New York City, pretty much, went to school
New York City my whole life I have lived here um
I mean New York city is pretty much my home, I mean that's
thats the place that I know, I mean I grew up, you know up
town, in Harlem um
a. You know I went to school, I met a lot of great friends and a lot of great
people. You know. I-I've been able to receive a pretty
decent education. Considering um the
schools that I went to, like PS 146 and
And um Junior High School 117 as well
as well as Mary Bircham they were all wheelchair accessible, which
was great becase I didn't have to worry about how I was
going to be able to navigate around school and um
. You know overall I have enjoyed my life
you know, like I said everything was
pretty much you know set up for me growing up, you know
PS 146, they had services that I needed, they had a para professional
for me, they had, uh
Physical and occupational therapy available
and um I was a mainstream student
Although I do have a disability, I've always been mainstream
growing up during my elementary,
junior high and high school years. And um
One of the things that my family always taught me is to never
use my disability as an excuse not to excel. um...
They always told me to do my best.
And to you know. Not let my disability
hold me back. They would hold me accountable, If for example
I didn't do as well as they knew I could, you know, and
my schoolwork and I was pretty much neck and neck with
my sister in terms of grades and you know
so on. um I have a twin sister and I
um I have an older sister. Actually I have many older
sisters, who have you know really helped to
encourage me throughout my life and
um If it wasn't for them, alot of the times I
probably would have been discouraged because I have gone through
that.
It hasn't been easy, um, but they've always
been there to tell me "Hey Jane, you know, you could do this. We want
you to do your best. um and we don't want anything.
Try to deter you from, you know, accomplishing your
dreams." um
It's been really helpful to me throughout my life
is my faith in my lord and savior, Jesus Christ um
God is, you know, without him again I wouldn't be
be able to um do the things that I do
I actually believe that he gives you the strength to wake up.
And to just do all the things that I'm
able to do in my life. I belive if it wasn't for him
I wouldn't even be here, I mean I feel that
He has a plan for me and I feel that, you know he's gonna
continue to guide me throughout.
my life's journey. You know, I- my faith
is really really what is the
driving force behind me.
Honestly I mean I wake up in the morning saying "ok Jesus, you
know.
Jesus I you gonna help me do you know whatever
it is that I need to do, whether it be just to be able to get up and go
take a shower or you know be able to ace
that final exam, you know, whatever it is! And I,
again, I think that faith is very important especially when you have a
disability because sometimes... I don't have
control over how my body moves and stuff like that
because of cerebral palsy, and
I think that it's um... important to know that
even if you don't have control, God does have control and he can
help you in the areas that you physically just can't really
do much about. I mean things that people take
like being able to hold books open
And hold an ice cream cone or something
like that, I find difficult at times, you know
because of my disability, you know, but, just
tapping into that faith and constantly thinking to myself
I know God is gonna to make it better, even
... or even if its just a little bit, sometimes I pray to God and he gives
me just a little bit more strength to do what I need to do.
Whether it be grabbing on to something or
or, you know, being able to pass, you know,
my exams or, you know, just getting into my
wheelchair in the morning - sometimes its a struggle, um... but
again is my faith and God, honestly keeps me going
really does. Do you go to a church around here?
Yes um, I actually attend First Sharon,
um, which is on a hundred sixteenth Street.
Um... and I think that the people there are really
know me since i'm a Kid and they, you know they
try to basically cultivate you know
my faith as much as possible and remind me that no
matter how difficult things may get God is always, you know, he always
always has my back, and so that,
you know, going to church and actually, you know,
learning about God from my grandmother
just constantly like focus,
you know, prayer and uh,
you know, just trusting God i-it's a big, it's a big,
it's a big help to me it really is, you know faith is-
is huge in my life. I wouldn't be able to like, I'm in
this society I
am in a National Society for leadership and success...
um, I currently have a 3.2...
seven -- I think -- GPA and
I have 49 credits
in college and I never thought that I would make it to this point
You know, with all that I have been through, you know, I don't
...
I didn't think that half of this would be possible
.
I honestly didn't. I mean, there were times where I just didn't think
that I will be able to manage, because sometimes I wake up
pain -- you know, physically, I've been through a lot of operations -- and
all kinds of things, things that would knock most people
down and make them say, "I just can't... you know I can't make it
I don't want to go any further," you know? But for some reason God is
always giving me a little bit of uh... it's like he's
always just telling me, "Don't worry Adrian, you and me
know we've got this. If you can't do, it I can!" You know
what I'm saying? So... that,
you know, I think faith is very,
very, very important. I really do think
that faith is... is actually... is
necessary. Like
to me it's almost as important as breathing, I mean if I
I didn't have my faith or if God
be here tonight.
So I just thank God for everything... I really
do. Mhm.
Can you talk more about w-what you're doing here at City College?
Um...
Well. I started off at City College, um...
wanting to be an education major -- I've always want to
teach. Um, I do work with some students here
I do do a little bit of tutoring here at times, um,
So it kind of helps me sort of fulfill
had when I originally came here... but unfortunately I had to make some
changes to my major. Because I
discussed it with some of my school
counselors at the disability offices at City
City College and um, like, Pat Bianchi,
you know, spoke to me and we spoke about how, because of my
physical disability, you know, teaching in a classroom full of
children might be difficult at times.
And, um,
you know we discussed me trying to find something that would be a
little bit more,
how can I say this... like something I would be able to handle better
um, considering my physical disability and what I was able
to do. Um, She wanted to ensure that I would
be able to be the best at whatever I'm doing and not let my
disability, sort of, like, you know,
put like, any kind of, like, you know
shadow over it, you know, and to make sure in
whatever I do my disability is not gonna, like, hinder me, or
you know, um... how
can I put this...
um, just get in my way basically.
Um, and so
I wanted to help people still, so I
decided that I would go into sociology because it's a pretty broad
field and you can, um,
learn about how to work with people in communities
and you know possibly do a job
that, you know, surrounds the Christian faith, like maybe
be a minister or maybe work with, you know, kids that at
afterschool program, or you know I'm not sure exactly what
I'm gonna do when I graduate but what I do know is that
I definitely want to serve others some way, you know?
Particularly, maybe, people with disabilities, I would like
to work with them and encourage them somehow you know
have a goal in life, so...
Uh... so, can you talk about,
uh...
like when you learned, um...
were you born with your disability?
Yes I was born with cerebral palsy.
Not really sure what the cause is of my disability, I believe it was
because of a loss of oxygen, but I'm really not sure.
And, because of cerebral palsy, I have had to
have many surgeries to try to correct the spasticity
that I suffer with in my muscles, um, to improve my
quality of life... and it's been a struggle because,
you know, it's like, when it's not one thing it's another.
But when you're dealing with cerebral palsy, it's like, I try to live my life almost...
it's almost as if I didn't have cerebral palsy, like, and I try not to
even let it... I try not to let it
influence
major parts of my life, I try not to
focus on it, you know, and make it be like a crutch,
you know, and say to myself, "Oh well I can't do this because I have
cerebral palsy." I try to say, "Okay.
I have cerebral palsy but. You know I can do
this: like for example, if they make a way
for me to go in to a school or a building as long as it's accessible,
you know, I can figure it out
some kind of way, you know. I don't let
disability stop me from doing anything that I wanna
do or accomplish... and for all of you out there listening
I wanna tell you: if you have a disability or even if you don't,
you know, don't let anything stop you from accomplishing what you
wanna accomplish. Every day is not gonna be easy but
if you have faith in God, He can show that what
you can't do, He can! And that is what I...
that is... try-that's how I try to live my life,
you know, I try to live my life saying that, you know, I have a
disability, yes, but let's see how we can work around it some
kind of way,
you know.
Always work around your disability, no matter what.
So what have...Can you think of any specific examples of challenges that you
faced and then managed to get around?
So many... where do I even start?
Like I said, I mean, I have difficulty with
something as simple as being able to hold the ice
cream cone with my left hand while I can drive
with my other hand... um, my left hand is, um,
weaker and harder for me to control than my right hand and
so that makes it a little bit
things that people take for granted I struggle
with.
I can't walk, and so, obviously, doing
things like being able to get up and just go use the restroom or,
you know, things that people don't even think about like even getting out of
bed in the morning... I can't do that by myself, you know, I have to
depend on somebody to come and help me everyday and
that's not easy... it can be quite challengin, you know, it really
can.
But, um, again, I just try to thank God for what I
do have, you know, because if I focus so much on what I don't have
then I'll get depressed, you know? So I focus on
what I do have as opposed to what I don't have, you know.
Because that way you can do a lot with what you have
. But when you... focus so much
on what you don't have or what you can't do, then you kind of
defeat yourself. To where you can't even do,
you know, things that you
probably would have been able to do if only you, you know,
realized what you were blessed with. I mean I,
you know,
So I have one hand that doesn't work so well that some people can't use
either word in their head and well I might not be able to move on but
at least my mind works well at least I can understand what's going
on around me and can you know take care of my
you know business market you know go to the
bank. I can you know come to school you know
come to college you know three days a week. Or
. You know I can go back and
it's you know so I try to focus on what it can do
and the glasses that I do have rather than focusing on
what I can't do or don't have.
That's when it ended.
To talk about can you talk about like the support that you've
received.
Oh lots of support from my
family my big sister
Montoya I.
Mean they have been they have just
instrumental in helping me
you know we had some you
. Know my. Mom. Has
difficulties you know. Mouses
family stepped in and helped you know
with pretty much everything and I mean from get
help in the lawn and then need to be
encouraged to go on when I have back pain
and you know. Whenever I didn't think at all.
Now I was in a college. Oh yeah because
you know they have muscle spasms in my back. They're like
there was nowhere to come back. Then and just felt
slow down because I have less than that's done before and I mean no that
didn't make it. I have twin sister. Came and so I
mean one day you know you can do this to me because I
. Knew you'd see how do you think you know the end
cause I'm saying you know basically
you were standing.
Why don't you do you know Chata come back because I had been away for a while
and hope it works. I mean have they arrive late
because when I had gone through all of them that you know
the masses came it was like oh you know I'm
not going to let you get up you know we have come so far
you know you've come so far I'm going to give up.
And so our family has been an amazing support
system really have him.
It is. Does anyone else in your family have disabilities. Yes
.
I have a cousin who hasn't. I mean he has he's
artistic. My grandmother
is blown away and
so I do have people in our family.
Girl who suffers from harm. He's mentally
impaired. So. I have quite a
few people. For.
Me.
This is a day even and
stymie a legacy and have me you know able to
basically prove that this is wrong and you know conquer their own
talent isn't fair I don't you know and I'd be honest
Brian. Well you know he's doing not
go she's doing and I find myself getting down and I think
and it gives me encouragement thinking oh
they're going to look outside of your family
. What kind of support he received.
Oh I see the whatever seem. Like I
have.
Kids I have. Home. Health care home health
thing you know people want to help me with my physical
you know and I have.
You know.
Needs a tricycle Cherokee not a physical therapy
leveling the housing to the daily you know getting
just believe me stuff like that and I also have access to
physical therapy as well as at
the hospital last time I asked
.
They you know I get a lot of support from them and
physical therapy.
The patient also is very
important for me because that helps me and it being he wants to
do something as simple as carrying a pocket book. You
know and that's really important for quality of life. Hence the
sun Why do you think it is to fill a
normal as possible. You know anybody who can
help you feel normal can
be. But I hope when you you know get dressed in the morning
or how do you come up with some kind of a handle that you can put
on your bag and carrying it is extremely
important for him I mean what if
it could
be like your childhood and
what it was like for you to go Whoa.
Well it was but it was also fun.
Because I have family members like.
I had a kind of the whole way because when I was little I did something
called a call on the floor because I couldn't
.
I couldn't. Use my legs. It's a
game day when he would fall on the floor if me to let me leave
late. We will play together before the Senate ask you
Phil included thatis possible to insist we
replay what we did do something where we use the play would be way
more intimate things that she might not be to our
my goals and then down on the floor and then get on the
floor with me and call around on the floor and pick up the.
This is lucky you know we made it out of the gate
when I was able to pick up those pieces and put it in the bucket so
as I was this is a much
different way and they can bring with them much more
insistent and I we would
rank she would play a video game. Sometimes it was hard for me to
play video games because there came to her home was made in a way
I couldn't believe it with my hands so she would
play the game.
I would watch him play in the game and I would say you
know how many you know. Only you
know a no go to this you know so it was kind of like I was
still playing in the game.
Even though I wasn't physically playing the game.
Do you remember the games they were always playing games on
Nintendo sixty four. We play for a station
games leave a game boy bands I mean you name it we
play me replace a Genesis one and laughing
. This is saying there you know
I don't believe any video game is
a time when there is in really did you ever play
Animal Crossing Claymore Animal Crossing.
No Oh well like Halo
and area act and there was a little bit right that came
when I was not so interested in getting someone like
that came after more of these you know
.
Where the Grand Theft Auto Grand Theft Auto.
No no but my family trying to discourage violence
as much as possible although we did play Mortal Kombat
.
Grand Theft Auto wasn't really a game that I have played a whole
lot because I think it was just a bit much.
You know Mario love mail
handling fame is my favorite game of on time and it
is high which is that's
an attendance sixty four but they have it now for
.
We and so on and I
was in a pretty poor.
Man's life past and I think it is
you know if you get home from school play video games
.
Well my parents.
Allow us to play video games that are
like my big sister. You know
they didn't really allow me to play video games
last we were in the know on Christmas vacation or even
finished our homework. We couldn't it was we couldn't come home
right away and play video games you know we had to make sure
their parents were pretty strict with that and I thank God for that
because it helps instill in the work ethic
that is in us now.
You know so.
Happy about that time it seemed a
little harsh but now that I am back and think about it
like they were right.
You.
Know so so what else are you
growing up like for you. Well.
Yes.
Sometimes it was hard because you know I had fun so
I didn't always work.
Is everyone else doing you know because well I came
on there you.
Know there were certain hand games day like we used
to play like a sister use that way to clean
with hand game that I was home for me because I couldn't turn
my face and I. Wish I always wished
you know because I was that plane. She wanted to play and
I you know we chatted.
You know we want to adapt. If she were thing I know is that the
game you know so that I was
.
You know that was a pretty important part of
. You know playing games in
my family that you know but it was hard because like
I said I had and then. And then my. Last is
. To work as well as there has
been for many years I wondered why you know
and then the stand or how can I look just like her
hair I get the same grades that's going to give everything else that
.
You know you can't like there's just so many.
I think you know what he's.
Like. No one around in the
playground and play you know on the way into it or
you know like.
I couldn't say Frances the pain they had these
places where we make
the kids will be claimed and you know
my family didn't put me you know
at this time I just couldn't understand that but you know I
was being left now and I don't understand that you know I mean again
because again my mind was work in the same way.
There was one of them I was thinking and just like any other kid and I just
physically couldn't do it you know and so that was hard.
Yeah that was hard you know. Yeah.
Oh do you. OK so you
focus instead on what you can and that's what I do
to you Don't you
can easily dig yourself into a whole question
of the day they spend so much time
you know being in being upset about what you can do to
save it. I don't half days when I wish I could do
this I can just get up and you know when I have
no wait for somebody to tell me you know things that most people
take for granted
. Yes I wish I could do those things but at the same time I
realize that there are people who are so much worse than I am.
They're people who can't even feed themselves they have people who have
feet and can't eat at all there are people who you
know have no feeling below the waist I mean you know
people who are standing
. So when I. Can.
Remember those people say Thank You got it released.
You know. All in goals and do this I mean I would be it wouldn't be
able to do this.
So maybe it will be worse if I couldn't do this all
of this land and then well I think last minute can't be
sound as I try to count my blessings instead of
counting you know the
effects this year because
.
You know.
So. What happened
then when I'm growing up growing up and
I mean Lincoln had a great chance. You.
Know left that which I meant gloomy as much as anything
. I went to the school and I get good grades
in high school and you know I graduated from high
school and I actually I have the accent doing high school and
actually I work very hard when I was high school I
was get instruction from teachers and I spent over
an hour on pages with tears and
rename pain that I had in my pants that me and I
graduated only a semester late which I'm pretty proud of
.
Any financial Yeah you know because.
My high school actually hosted a program where
we got to participate in those tours
and we got some learn about like the
offices of the college you know and
so they could be hopeful for you in college
where you would be able to get no steak.
And you would be able to.
Have access to a tape recorder in case you think you know
fast enough ahead and time one examines that you know
that was really important because.
I was very nervous about what I don't know I would be able to change
into college because I didn't know if any services would
be available to me as a person and in the end it
and some that was pretty much you know I have the
highest score that was pretty much where it was going oh
.
You know well that's helping me to restart you know what would be
a good school for me and what services would be available to
me want to say the least bit and that was pretty much
. Wow You know after a child you
know get into and from an early you know high
school and college that you know that was a pretty long
journey for me it really was I don't know I don't. Bumps in
the road.
Says you're a fan of the family.
Well I would still get the jewelry and I hope
that I continue to have it. Just
people aren't flying into. Book and
surgeries. You get oh OK well not all of
us and we release it is in the back of my
surgeries I just let my legs you know just
been able to move your lungs
. Oh yeah.
Some surgeries were somewhat helpful...
um... like, for example, I had surgeries on my ankles to help straighten out
my feet more because my muscles would twist my feet around so
it helped me to be able to put on, like, shoes
and do things that, you know, you or anyone else wouldn't even
think about... but I don't
know if,
I mean some of them were
helpful, and I don't want to go into detail about them too much,
you know, but others seem like it was just, you know,
almost like they were just experimenting on me or something, you
know, because it didn't really help a whole lot.
I ended up having to get sometimes double
done, like, they would do one surgery and something would happen
and they would have to operate on the same area again, you know, years later
So... it... it's been a tough road, it really has.
But God is good, so I'm
not complaing, you know, He... He's
been good, I'm really happy.
So where do you -- we didn't go over -- where... where you live
Where I live?
Where exactly? Like the street. I live in East Harlem
I live, um,
I live in El Barrio, right near,
um...
Near 116th Street.
Yeah...
Is there anything that you would talk about -- touch upon -- that we haven't talked about yet?
Uh...
I think I got a pretty good... um... I
covered a lot of areas. I covered school
like family stuff
Do you want to talk - Going to church which was -- which is -- big for
for me... really big for me... mmm, that's
pretty much, you know... Do you want to talk about
your parents, what they do? Well...
my -- well my dad passed away,
my mom is,
she has a disability, so she wasn't able to work.
Um... but yeah, I mean that's...
I mean they... like I said they didn't work, but um
what I can say is that they were very big on education
and they always tried to
encourage us to, like, do very well in school
focus on our books, focus on learning, uh
My dad was a huge black history buff, I mean, he taught me a lot
about black history and with everything that's going on today
uh, you know with the police
brutality and
you know all these, sort of, movements, that are
going on right now, I-I tend to think about
him a lot, you know... and I miss him a lot, you know?
Especially seeing what's going on around me today
even feeling a little scared being, you know,
African-American and being in this country it just [sighs]...
sometimes I wonder if I'm really truly a citizen the way they
treat, you know, my people. It-it is scary
it really is.
Just got to keep on keeping on I guess. You know, keep
fighting and don't let anything get us down, you
know? That's all we can do. You can't
give up, you can't -- no matter how much
opposition there seems to be out their, we can't let it get to us.
You know, because then what is there if you give up
you got nothing left.
So um, we are talking, or you were talking -- About my dad. You're right, your dad, yeah.
Yeah I mean with everything going on,
um,
With this... with the police
brutality and the things that African-Americans continue to
suffer through in this country, I mean, I can't help
but think about him because... he
always wanted us to know who we were
and to know our history and know what people went through
they're spending today. You know.
And. Seeing everything is going on you know in
vision and
.
Everything else and then. You.
Know and the government that's one of the things they're really I mean I don't
feel bad. I think I should go off.
On you know but I
mean I you. Know
somebody.
Who said you know he just wanted us to know who
we want to be brought up and we ran to.
Let anybody make us feel this is because again
you know I'm saying in the sea and everything it goes around now
it's like back in the nineteen sixties
and you feel like Whoa Whoa Whoa Whoa Daddy say ever since he
was not right what his take on this and on
the other hand I'm happy day.
You know he's not around to see this because I think
that it would be really.
You think he would be sad to see what words
mean scary because I feel like instead of taking a step forward we've taken a step
back in this country.
What.
Do you think this type of stuff has been going on but
finally right now we're dealing with it as a country all along.
Yes definitely I think it's been going on on time.
It's almost like a
park and while I am friendly is
you know it blew up and nineteen sixty you know and the
fifty's I mean Martin Luther King and all those you know guys were
watching for us and. Everything in our hands brought
to our attention and. And it was like oh it
was placed around and now is being is and I'm a
prat has blown open again. People are looking
at the issue again because this is really something. This is like a
hot day and it's always been turned on it's just day
has been simmering for the past fifty years or so
or even hundreds of years going and it's never been
fully tested
. So finally you know people dressing it
has been an issue for you sent us here
. Yes it's like a
practice distance them and using using his final You
blew it blew the lid blew off it and
that's where there is.
Can you talk about living in Harlem during this time in history and what you've
seen going on I. Mean.
An intense family reunion Hello I mean I don't really
see a whole lot I don't like living up here and I'm not
too concerned because it's very bad you know it is but I don't you
know different groups the people everybody is pretty much you know
except this thing
is you know them here so we have not had to go
away you know both family members live in doubts
. I often.
You know I have worry about you know worrying about
me you know having to
live in these times you know one day
weekends.
What was it like around here after that.
Trial and after
luncheon you know I mean people are Martian people felt
like you know what happened I was a fan I mean people funnily
there was no justice here around. The area
here. They weren't happy about what happened
. It's like we you know
it's like we will change is if we going out there and we know now that
it's because I'm doing this I don't think that's fair
you know.
Who can I listen
to it.
OK So what about your your mom
.
She asked him name Linksys one and strongest people
know. She has. Been
a rock.
For almost thirty years and he see with
you know me and for me they want me. She
ran to every point with me. She went every
see me whenever bracelets and the discipline and
she only put them on. She was always very
patient with me. Any mental
accomplishment and I mean well then be academic or physical.
She always was you know proud of me
. Yeah I mean she's since been wonderful to me as
it's been an absolutely wonderful thing that
like. I'm a disability you don't you have
.
Nothing to say. She has
no you know she she has been able to
you know make two. Then I am going to do the same
thing. Sprayed it as well.
And it was a growing up she did the best she
could you know
.
There are any words you have from the recording.
Well. I think they.
Who have this list if you. Have time in your life who have you
are I think they have a
fear like you just can't go on. I want to invite
you to say I'm praying to Jesus curries
in heaven I want to pray and ask
Cantona hope you are aware of the you may be going through because
you know. No matter what your circumstances may change
but the Lord will never change and so I think there
is definitely same trainer to move into this crisis if you
find yourself in turmoil and he
will help you knowing who you know
. That is a man who can do
you know.
Well Jane Jane it's a pleasure speaking with you.
We want to mention on the recording about your
husband. Yes and who he is how you met him
. Well.
Spent in school his name is George.
And he's been really a great guy.
He he also has a very. He
was born with it as well. We met in school
and.
He is and put his.
It's almost like a missing link from the sentencing and they just
don't seem like big government
. He's like oh he's kind of like a clue
to changes in a way. Please Me Like
it's.
Standing upright absolutely backwards he says he's the
person you can't just me and that's where I'm
standing up.
And I met we you know I met him in
kindergarten. I haven't even know that he liked me until I was
seventeen years ago and he acts me out of school
bus home.
It's like OK you
know I need to know he was going to marry me and it's I want to. He was
crazy and he said.
He basically you know it is you know Prime
Minister I mean to send it he would write school
and high school.
You know we didn't know I graduated we
continue to have to we had some ups and downs in
our relationship just like anybody else.
Ah well I think again our faith
is what has strengthened our relationship and I
think if it wasn't a phase marriages and
you haven't this is the same
thing the same kind of challenges you deal with the same kind of
issue you know. Sometimes you
can be really tough times. And great
in this kind of have to keep trying but I
think it's nice to be married because it's the nice to have somebody
so it's time to when you feel like you don't have any men
.
He's very shy and. Is more quiet.
Now he started to open up a little bit more on what he's
always been someone to co-write a guy.
I'm a little out go in and you know they get
a B. and things you know
they are sent the tiny plane where Judge is
more content to just sit back in the bag and
.
What is the point is that people know I
have cerebral palsy and the you
know blind or whatever you might find
yourself up against you have there
is always hope for me
. Anybody get married doesn't matter that you have a
disability. Don't think just because you have in this
case because somebody out already I think I have a plan for
everybody you know so you know never give
up even if everyone else around eternal name is going to
happen though.
Believe me he is not possible for God he
didn't do any you know.
That's pretty much you know.
Really again it's great to have
.
You know I have to go out and be looking around the place it
be in holy matrimony as opposed to thinking
Oh no you know it's nice to be able to have their
commitment and being came with this campaign not to say it
is not very hard because you know he would have
you know but. Again a faith you know keeps
manage going you know. But I did
read his Bible and he helps me get home
up through my marriage and you know printing let me
spank them a fair I mean. There have been times where it's
just it's just been so hard and I think been in
situations where I just wouldn't be able to
manage one of us they have planned and all of a sudden you
know it's like he's failing because God
gives me a boost you know he gives me some straight.
We know that nothing is impossible. Tyler
is nothing is impossible. That
is you can become parents. If you can't go to
kindly you can be in you know
study and or trade school or you could you.
Know when I have what I am you know I can't live no
way you can do it. He may do it in different ways and they might be
harder to do and one thing I'm going to do it and I was going to
take me back I was there I don't plan on
stopping I'm going to keep going. Because I know
one of these days. When it's carried.
I don't know how long it's going to take our hope and finish by twenty twenty
but then again I will know
that you can turn this thing you've started Don't give up
keep on going keep on
trying.